Once Upon a Time in ancient Greece the
city-states of Sparta and Argos were
feuding over a fertile strip of land and
sent out their armies when the two
armies met they decided that instead of
senselessly fighting over the land and
losing thousands of people in the
process they will have 300 of their
strongest soldiers fight to the death
and whoever had the last man standing
will win both armies also agreed that
they would go back to their respective
cities in order to not influence the
battle the battle took an entire day and
once night fell two archive soldiers
were the last man standing with no
Spartans in sight thinking they had won
the archives returned to their city and
announced their Victory but unbeknownst
to them they left behind a Spartan
soldier who was wounded but not defeated
he dragged himself up with a broken
Spear and remained guard at the Battle
side thinking that since he was the last
man standing on the field he was the
Victor when both cities found out they
both thought they won the Battle of the
Champions they went to war anyways which
was the very thing they were trying to
prevent